final exam tips
two things firstly your brain but your
brain is attached to a body
okay so before your exams the night
before
you need to sleep okay i've had so many
students come to me and tell me ah
sir i was after 2am because i was
finishing this past paper or something
like that
okay i was finishing this exercise so
i'll be ready for the next day
which is sort of the equivalent of
shooting yourself in the foot really
because if you
sleep at two what time you get up what
time you get up to go to school
six seven five really wow far okay
so you're getting you're pulling three
four hours of sleep
your brain's gonna be running at like 40
it's going to be slower you won't
remember stuff
it's a bad idea okay so you need to get
sleepy for exams
and the second thing is i have to give
this um
this warning because some of you not
into this type of thing and um it's
going to be a bad piece of advice if you
follow it
but if you're generally pretty sporty
and you can see yourself quite
fit then wake up early right
and go for a run before your exam okay
or at least a walk okay your brain it
operates on
uh glucose oxygen all delivered there by
blood
if you're getting up and moving right
your brain will be much more active when
you get into that exam
and you're not going to do that thing
which we all do in section one you make
really silly errors because your brain's
actually not started up yet
okay so assuming it won't kill you
because you're unfit
um go get up go do a 10 15 20 minute run
whatever
and it'll really help you okay right